you know in the first jurassic park
movie there was that scene with the
glass of water in the car's cup holder
with ripples on it to show just how
heavy the approaching t-rex's footsteps
were well this thing behind me is
technically called the large mobile
shaker but the folks here at the
university of texas they call it the
t-rex because it's a machine designed to
shake the ground itself we have five
shakers they go from a small one that's
right behind me and we call that an
urban shaker because you can bring it
downtown and not get into trouble
shaking and then we have very very large
ones liquidator and t-rex liquidator is
a low-frequency vertical shaker where we
generate surface waves like surface
waves from earthquakes but ours are
linear typically and earthquakes can be
non-linear
[Music]
t-rex is a tri-axial shaker tri-axial
means that the shaker only one at a time
it can shake vertically it can shake
horizontally and it can go transverse it
can go up to about 60 000 pounds force
vertically and about half horizontally
the t-rex is on a fairly low setting
right now but don't worry we're going to
be turning it up shortly it doesn't feel
like much here right now but we'll get
there and you might think this would
just be used for destructive technical
validation computer models no this is
useful for research and execution we
have been all over the united states we
have sensors that we've designed and we
will push in because they're pushing
rams on the back of liquidator and t-rex
so that we can install sensors and then
watch the wave go down many times we're
watching the wave propagate away from us
but other times it's very helpful to
have watch the wave going down and
seeing how
poorly the soil might behave due to
large amplitude shaking which is what
you don't want we've now switched to
horizontal shaping and this is about
part of what we recommend i've been an
earthquake once in my life it was very
slight but it felt like this ground
underneath my feet the things to rely on
right now it just isn't stable anymore
we just came back from wyoming
where
they're
going to build
new power plants
and
the earthquake design is critical and we
generated
a six thousand foot long wave now we
generated a two foot long wave too but
going through the range so that means we
could evaluate the stiffness profile
down to a half a mile
with no boreholes
that is really
a true
accomplishment
and a very very cost effective addition
to the design of the plant so this is a
sensor
it's a big magnet with a coil the coil's
going through the magnetic field we were
out there in wyoming and the darn cows
walked by
fortunately they didn't break any cables
but we had to stop testing because they
made more noise they were right out
there and we were a half a mile away and
this is the highest setting that the
team were allowed to use here on campus
just show off the weaknesses 27
being punched in the ground only 10
oh my goodness every time we go
someplace we'll make sure the level
won't damage structures once we were on
the ucla campus and maybe didn't watch
what we were doing so much and people
came running out of the building and
that got us in trouble
[Music]
you